right here some quick details 62 players
average rating 1840 30 minutes craziness
experience level 30 here we go here we
go here we go it's just started this is
a tough first game oh
or is it who has won ha ha ha quick hill
that's a good start confused rain last
time I did not confuse this guy try a
gambit now that's different now that
it's definitely different isn't it I'm
not one for gambits why did I go for
that ok throw my knight in here right in
here ok that's not really so much of an
issue
that is not really so much of an issue
although I'm on the Queen I'm also on
the night that was missed I was gonna
take with my rook because my bishop
would have been very powerful ok Queen
here I feel like I should be smashing
open at this square Bishop takes pawn is
very strong Bishop takes pawn rook takes
King h7 is mate Queen block
Queen check and then rook here I get the
Queen this is covered on d1 that's
pinned let me take that first and then
oh that's gonna be main that's a quick
win back to tournament high 5 whoo 5 to
1 I think many are still just playing
the first game whoa that's a good start
out of the gates right there it's a good
one here we go are they gonna pair me up
on that last tournament that wasn't uh
that wasn't the greatest start in the
world right
our first one didn't alright it just was
a time ticker and then Oh going for
scholars mates man
you see what happens go ahead you try it
you try it you fall for the scholars me
and then see and then see how you like
it to see all these players trying to
get you and the scholars me uh-oh I'm on
this poem got him I should have given
check first take the rope though he's
free he's a freebie and now I'm gonna
rescue the bishop with that last move
pawn push okay this is this is
definitely quite all right Forks this is
very dangerous this is this is game over
isn't it there's nothing to relieve and
watch out for get the Queen's off no
issues no issues this night out of there
no let's just get here guess Bishop
there push this pawn push the pawn and
then get this right here pin that night
my bishops are brutal brutal Bishop's
push the pawn a couple times made on
each one coming up
there's no stalemate you have the apon
unavoidable back to tournament 1111 six
and a bunch of two's okay I need to get
some lead so I could have a cushion in
case I lose I need some cushion I need
some cushion okay
reinforce d4 because it's gonna come
under heavy fire with nearly every black
move Queen b6 okay not just yet but the
queen up queenside castle I think I
could do I'm not afraid of that check
I'll go no I should have I should have
done that I needed to stick around on c4
it's the bishop gonna play here no it's
not let's do this to walk now I'm on the
knight actually now on that night pawn
push next maybe even sack right here and
this square okay what do we have an
in-betweener width check I might throw
another in between her and with Jack
nope Knight takes here on the Queen this
is following a
I know okay I'll go with this maybe not
the best but if the knight moves its
mate no he has to take the pawn I got
the knight though this is gonna be made
to threat
I get the bishop where's the bishop
gonna go right here in h3 or g4 d7 is
not good because I get the knight in
then the bishop making to threat rook
takes Knight and then that discovered
tricks actually mate next right here is
mate so the bishop can't block back
determine 19-6 what's going on I have a
bunch of wins in oh man this guy is so
fast this guy is just way too fast
I shouldn't even I don't even notice I
can't I can't commentate commentate hang
on can we get the Queen's off everybody
knows I'd love to get the Queen's off um
I'm the bishop in this pond I mean that
dark square bishop okay where am I going
now steak I could give it a chat a block
right here I could block right there was
my dark square Bishop doing pawn up and
then no let's do this first I just
grabbed the night man that's a free
night ah man I have to start taking free
pieces to start taking free pieces man
on the Queen Queen trade maybe I should
take that pawn one day not now not now
nope let's just come back here I'm not
sure why I just can't explain everything
my bishop wants to be here
I want a double rooks oh man this guy is
just way too fast it's it's not fair I'm
gonna try a Queen trade again another
Queen trade possibility would sack that
the knight jumps in there on the rook
it doesn't feel like that's a good move
I don't okay now I'm gonna do this I got
to take with this pawn connected okay
this has to be good now right on the
rook give a check pawn push okay this
has to be good this has to be good time
is actually balancing out this is still
okay and a prima of that time is okay I
was ready to take with my pawn here no
matter what push my pawn no matter what
push this pawn no matter what King
position I should have done that let's
come back over here pawn push do this
and then that here take here look here
no matter what I'm gonna give a check I
need time burners or the time burners
where are those time burners the check
pawn push they don't have any time
usually I'm running out of time Oh 29
and a bunch of 12s oh man I'm just
losing my breath I'm just I just lose my
breath and okay I got a pawn though no
why no way I have to watch out for f2
getting dizzy here getting dizzy
okay let's this is just should be okay
I'm not afraid of double pawns I'm out
the pun take that Queen trade I love it
I love the Queen's coming off I never
met a queen trade I did not like that's
an exaggeration Knight there what is
Knight doing he was getting a bit too
reckless right there he was definitely
reckless contest the file I will take
that and then hunt that pond down
hunting the pond down is the plan and
then get it f7 this Bishop is stable
hang on hang on there we go grab this
pawn and then there's no issue watch out
for my lips okay where's the main my
opponent is stuck
and they are officially stuck I should
have grabbed that okay what am i doing
oh okay this is a past pun he's fast now
he's a very fast pump on push and I'm
gonna do this this is gonna be my trick
get my king up to h6 and then look for
me the king is in a box gotta watch out
for stalemate I guess I'll take that
though that's me back to China
41:30 I have a slight cushion here 41:30
24 Matthew oh my goodness is this the
guy oh my goodness come on this has to
stop right now
should I start taking offense yeah you
gotta play against that national master
he falls for that thing called the
scholars me he throws a laughing fit oh
man oh my goodness
scholars male and that's slightly
dangerous I gotta do that that was um I
should have avoided that that was not I
want to get my should we got my bishop
here sooner Bishop takes pawn was a
threat
I promise putting a lot of pressure on
me I know I don't really not a fan of
the Hat that's a great statement right
there yes because other people are a fan
of that
okay um opposite colored bishops I guess
I guess it'll be okay Bishop here okay
now I can finally get some dark square
control I'm dropping that pond I've been
dropping that pond I'm not dropping that
pond what am I even doing though what am
I even doing I don't even know
Queen trade where's the Queen trade pawn
push come over here if the pawn pushes
just come over here anyhow I want to get
here Queen trade mmm over here bishop
grab the pond okay
I'll do that now the G file is looking
good
Queen trade Queen trade is all I ever
want I'm getting what I want I think I
got what I want
okay now things are a lot smoother
pinpoint this pawn on the bishop of a
wild rook that I almost dropped how much
chopped I really wanted to go to that
seventh rank very bad very bad I need
some pre moves here I just have to
believe me you're just gonna have to
believe me on that one okay
primo of time primo of time keep
everything glued together run pawn your
past and you're fast and you cannot be
cop
that's mate no matter what no it's not
over here ring-around-the-rosie
variation I've seen this before back to
tournament 55 42 42 just when you think
you're gonna get that King does that uh
he just runs around you can't get him
fifty five forty two forty two thirty
thirty okay this is this the guy that I
played last tournament that gave me a
beating no I don't think it is Becky was
it something that started would it be
okay I just I can't even turn away I
think the last tournament I went to go
check out some games that were going on
as soon as I jumped away from this it
started up is it gonna do that again I'd
rather have it come up and then I can
make a pre move I want to see some other
games in any game nothing here
well it says nothing here still I have
to keep going back every other second
nothing still what's happening here come
on armchair here we go you see here we
go yes get those double those points
okay I have a nice Center and I want to
do what I should have castled well
actually it's okay
gain some space reinforced my furthest
advanced pond and get opposite the clean
okay let's opposites Heights castling
let's open up some stuff
let's open up some stuff here get out of
there night what's going on here keep
going the a file can now open up I think
95 was best now I'm dropping where
they're dropping upon maybe more if they
don't see I'm covering a a6 pawn push
and the night okay let's just keep going
with this I wanna get rid of the
LightSquared Bishop actually I want to
watch about not moving my knight for one
Bishop yeah I want to protect my knight
and Bishop here is actually threatened
to win the Queen Wow
now that is tricky trying to remove my
knight actually I could have taken it
but the bishop would take because my
night would be guarding that still on
the Queen okay okay so this is closed up
let's reinforce this pawn I guess this
is all clogged up for as long as this
pawn remains here the bishop is kind of
dead I'm okay with giving up the
exchange I'm not okay with being down on
time though whoa come on here it's some
pre moves I want to get at this pawn no
matter what okay time is actually
balancing out here hon push I could do
at any moment I really just don't want
to do that though drop back get my
knight in here and then to this square I
should have maybe been doing that sooner
much sooner grab here actually a fork a
saddle would be nice ah something I
missed in my opponent just missed okay
width check things are looking good time
wise just watch out for the back rank
actually no matter what I should maybe
be doing h3 soon okay back to tournament
leaders leaders leaders 71 56 56
arm-chair this guy's up there or no he
was the one that I was rooting for in
that game cuz he was playing against a
top guy okay we're having this okay this
is not this is not going to lead to any
quick wins is it
okay no it's not not allowed or maybe it
is maybe I have a my opponent knows well
he definitely knows about h2 I might
still try it though maybe not hang on
let's see okay let me get let me go this
way too well it's not even gonna go in
that direction I'm getting this pun oh
what's that about
I was interesting that was a slick move
right there okay now I'm gonna hit the
Queen I'm also on the rook I'm gonna see
that I'm gonna see that they're not
gonna see that actually on the Queen
still and I'm on the rook everything is
now falling they might resign they
resigned back to tournament 89 56 56 55
54 14 halfway point X the future okay oh
I have a nice Center still have a nice
Center is my sin are gonna be challenged
when is it gonna be challenged okay I'm
not sure I'm afraid of that unless
there's okay I don't know about this
okay dark square bishop I want to get on
this diagonal yeah it comes with tempo I
could do a pawn push up on blocks
hitting the night he has to run to a
different square and I thank out 95
Queen d2 watch out for the f4 square he
could still be kicked away I want to
open up this position whoa Mike on is
trying to fishing pool mean maybe I'll
take that night in a better at a better
point here I don't even know why I did
that
somebody tell me why I did that we get
rid of this Bishop it's kind of scaring
me
I know it's actually a good idea take
the bishop with check take the knight
and then I have Queen a6 stuff and then
a I could take the knight actually I
could take the knight next I'm taking
the knight now because I could give a
check and then take on g4 or just take
right here and just defend it directly I
want to stop Queen h4 stuff rook here I
could give a check give a check take
right here and actually oh I got the
Queen no I got me that's me in the
corner back to terminal
109 I was too fixated on stopping the
Queen from getting to h4 that wasn't
needed I had a better attack 109 TS
TSC press this guy is up there with 72
important game okay all right to baby
step this here a small pond center put a
question of the bishop and if it takes i
take with the night so I could get my
darks for a bishop out if not I expand
centralize my night I'm on the light
square bishop and I think I want to get
rid of that guy before he kills me get
my other night doing something on the
dark squares being counted the bishop no
pawn push is probably close to happening
isn't it I could play here let me just
defend stuff with my knight I want to
get that night out of there actually
went away voluntarily and I missed that
oh man I saw that in that or some game
I'm reminded of with that okay anyhow if
the knight plate here that would have
been a bad pre-move I'm dropping this
pawn no I'm not take with my bishop on
there I'm on this if pawn push then this
becomes very weakened okay I guess I
have to take care of this pawn if it
moves I get the knight if it moves here
I get the rook take this open the light
squares I can't even take grab that okay
the bishop here even though I'm down
upon 30 seconds each I'm on the knight
my bishops hopefully could do something
good
oh I'm on the night I was gonna okay I
was gonna break at this point if I my
opponent didn't drop that I wanna I want
to challenge this pawn and get at this
point that was my plan undermined this
this this pawn right here I can't even
get my dark square bishop working okay
I'm gonna drop my light square Bishop
back I want to remove the glue of the
position the glue is this guy get rid of
him and I think things become squeaky
clean this rook is pinned and I don't
know how it gets out of that pin so
easily Derek there it goes what's easy
enough where's that easy button where is
it okay my king wants to do something I
promise you he's gonna inch his way over
here and I promise you he's going to
eventually attack this pawn or not we
come here stop the pawn from moving and
then get my rook active I'm gonna
sacrifice for that pawn give a check
watch out for discovered tricks that
comes with check I could do a bunch of
pre moves now get my King finally doing
something my bishop is there
to defend okay down there down on time
back to Chairman 1:29 101 88 hat comic
11 minutes remaining
caro-kann main line no we're not even
having that we're having something else
and my queen is being attacked I just
had flashbacks of that game when I
dropped my queen in the beginning
Nicolaas that game okay I have a giant
Pond Center and maybe an attack against
the king that was a mouse look I did not
want to do that open up this file I want
to get at this pond I'd also like to get
my bishop here and then break up this
square much easier I can throw my knight
in the center if it's kicked away it
might be case of chasing the night away
to ask where I wanted to go 294 Bishop
h6 can it moves queenside castle Bishop
d3 h4 h5 ideas as well my opponent is
down you can't see it on the screen you
might see a little bit of a shadow near
this top rank it says that they
disconnected and they're gonna lose
within 30 seconds if they don't return
so what you do in the meantime is some
homework and see who was on your heels
who's on my heels okay actually my
opponent is back they returned they
returned from being disconnected there
was also a threat of something there I
think with Bishop h4 for his longing
Lion King was on the e-file I'm just
dropping that oh man okay fortunately
they don't have time to put to use that
extra piece could still just take on
this square maybe Bishop here Queen
check and grab on g6 come in check
oh I'm defending that with my rook that
was missed oh I got the Queen they're
down on time though anything back to
tournament 149 121 who is this guy 149
121 88 9 minutes remaining d galantis
okay everybody's playing f4
Eve for okay pawn push all right I'll go
with this I'm gonna get in d6 okay hang
on
well I was gonna do Queen here to induce
the light square weakness my knight
really gonna be taken I want to
challenge this pawn I think very soon
but at first Castle because otherwise
Queen here I don't my knight around if
your opponent has control over f6 there
could be some issues with your Kings
side give a check on push okay let me
take cuz now there's no queenside castle
my bishop out to an active square and
I'm gonna play here stop King side
castle well okay Queen shade you know I
feel about that you know how I feel
about that get my King doing something
something good here pawn push might be
good let's see I'll be okay with that I
think my king what do we want to do here
I wanted to get my rook on b4 now it
can't go there but I want to get active
like this Haruka is very active I get it
this pod no I want my rook to be where
right here is very active
maybe undermine this pawn soon I'm
getting a pond definitely getting a pond
this one Falls and now my D pawn has
passed so the next step is to undermine
this structure if I could get at this
pawn there's not gonna be much to do I
think I'm inching closer to being able
to do stuff not quite this rook over
here is gonna be a problem I think let's
do this no my other rough gets involved
and maybe back up a pressure on this and
now both my Brooks are active and my
opponent's trucks are passive now I'll
trade now I can get this pawn with check
and then this one next everything's
falling if check I just read I just
block with my rook give a check and now
March March my passed pawn and keep
marching support my broke out my other
pond working my opponent cannot make any
progress let's just get the rooks off
and then over here they're down on time
as well back to tournament 169 whoo
pretty good lead there 169 119 Kirk
Fischer Kirk Fischer okay
all right this is something that I play
is black a lot but normally black would
like to get that light square Bishop out
before II 6 is played okay build my
center I want to get in d5 d5 open this
position up look for a fork as well
there's a fork this is gonna be a
problem
let's drop you know I could get my I
could get trapped okay this can i think
rook takes is available okay that's not
being played rook takes was there but I
think it would have been a pan I could
have gotten out of I could take here cuz
they're in a pin now they are in a pin
and I'm up a full rook hang on let's do
that that's a better pre move back to
Turman Oh 189 139 six minutes remaining
got a pretty good lead here two games a
two-game lead to game lead five minutes
remaining
uh-oh it's not getting paired up here
got Michael Myers right on my tail or
actually not right on my tail but he's
around scary thought scary thought that
is c5 96 pressure on D I want to open
the position up this is not advancing
White's development and you see that
pressure on B and let's see I want to
get in b4 this is actually a good thing
half open a file my opponent is helping
me to undermine but I'm not done yet I
want to crack at this pond because the
removal of this pond on C means that my
C pond becomes past
I played my Bishop out because I didn't
want their book to play to be one after
b5 so G for I come back here everything
is fine now that I have control over
this B 5 B 4 and this pond is going to
drop at any moment
I would think he's just very very weak
darts cribbage would come out in fact
Bishop to a6 to b2 is in 83 to b2 is
another idea and I think this is a
cleanest approach the knight is pinned
there is no castling I don't know if I
even want a castle just came to East 7th
followed by rook here but no similar to
my bishops controlling b1 they are
controlling b8
my night on d7 can use some work he's
doing nothing I'll get him working next
I guess pawn push can happen soon
tricky Forex that would actually be made
oh that was close to main is this mate
where's the main where's the mate
there's got to be something something
good here pawn push is a late is a main
whoa is a late what am I talking about
that was a was a slick made there with
the pawns I was controlling a lot of
squares near the king the king of the
cube is here king of the cube French
defense four minutes remaining
okay I was just played Knight f3 Queen
is close to being trapped close close to
being trapped Queen here
backup and then play here just actually
I'm in a castle first I want to be able
to capture towards the center I didn't
have that available um okay I feel like
I'm gonna be getting out trapped soon
and really take I just back up that's
why I did that so I can meet f4 with
just a retreat throw my knight in here
you know what I'm looking for actually
do pawn push keep a light square
blockade although this Bishop comes to
life for Queen exchange and get that and
how'd that happen
33 seconds it was just missed Oh quick
resign quick resign back to tournament
resignation to 29 168 free minutes
remaining I'm running away I think with
this one not always the case if this is
the first one you're watching you missed
out
beating in the other beating I should
have taken in that last tournament the
loss and the loss that I should have had
in other words okay my knight wants to
be on f4 it's a good square I talked
about that in the five minute games
earlier in the stream f4 and f5 if
you're casted on the Kings side getting
a knight to those squares very dangerous
and I can't allow this pawn push to come
in I don't think back up my rook I think
wants to be on see my queen wants to be
on a I want to be out of this pin okay
there other pin I have the darks for a
bishop but he's stupid
he's stupid how can I get him so he's
not stupid
my Knights on that for my opponent does
not have a darks for a bishop so this is
a precursor to bad things happening for
white a knight on f4 tricky stuff
happening on g2 let's see about that I'm
hitting the night Bishop takes Bishop
I'm on the night I'm hitting here if the
knight moves it's made its mate g2 - 49
179 172 149 here we go this is maybe the
last game open Sicilian yes I'm going to
take that night and then just develop if
I could move quicker I want to get an F
for Queen e2 first maybe e5 let me do a
5 f4 f5 my light-square bishop is dead
if my opponent really wants it I'm gonna
just reinforce my center or just have my
seat pon control on some way to the
control of the Senate I can't even take
that what am i doing okay change of
plans I want to eliminate the dark
square Bishop how can I do that okay now
let me get it c5 okay
c5 is where I want to be c5
mmm I really don't wanna give that up
pawn push I have enough coverage on and
I believe I still have enough coverage
on I have two minor pieces and a pond
you can't really overtake that maybe
they're afraid of Bishop takes pawn I'm
really not that's it I say it's actually
a bluff really wouldn't take that I'm
bluffing now I'm bluffing
I need a flight square I think my knight
wants to be on f4 I guess all of a
sudden wants to be on the f4 tricky
stuff Knight f6 does that really work 27
seconds each time it didn't finish not
even close to finishing we still had
about 27 seconds each first-place
confetti land whoa all right 249 208 179
172 a close battle for third place going
on there any one of these guys could
have gotten it all right the game's aw